in the distance an outdoor market stand
wants an empty emblem of the lockdown
now an icon of hope from Monday moving
forward to fill these streets again
changing the subject after a difficult
week Boris Johnson called today's
announcement for England limited and
cautious but the moves will make a big
difference from Monday we will allow up
to six people to meet outside provided
those from different households
continues strictly to observe social
distancing rules we will now allow
people to meet in gardens and other
private outdoor spaces these changes
mean that friends and family can start
to meet their loved ones perhaps seeing
both parents at once or both
grandparents at once putting the whole
top team out on the day Darren police
say Boris Johnson's top aide might have
broken lockdown rules was not going to
be plain sailing
twice the scientists were asked if his
actions had heard public compliance with
the lockdown twice the Prime Minister
interjected and stopped them from
answering are you entirely comfortable
with the Prime Minister telling you that
you can't answer questions about Dominic
Cummings that if you can't give a verbal
answer an order or a shake of the head
will suffice and is there anything else
the Prime Minister has told you not to
answer on the desire not to get pulled
into politics is far stronger on the
part of a Patrick and me than it is in
the prime minister and a civil servant
I'm political I don't want to get
involved in politics at all but they are
nervous about whether the public follow
remaining lockdown rules given that
there is so little margin for error we
still have a significant burden of
infection we are still seeing new
infections every day but quite a
significant rate and the are is close to
one that means there is not a lot of
room to do things and things need to be
done cautiously step-by-step and
monitored and the tests and trace system
needs to be effective
in order to manage that Scotland making
similar moves to England today garden
centres reopening non-contact sports
allowed and eight rather than England
six people allowed in a garden from
tomorrow the regulations or in meeting
other people will change you and your
household will be able to meet with an
other house household out of doors for
example in a park or in a private garden
we said last week this should be in
small groups and to give you greater
guidance on that we're asking that the
total number of people between the two
households meeting up should be a
maximum of eight still stay at home as
much as possible the virus has not gone
away lockdown is being modified slightly
it is not over the rules are becoming
more complicated as restrictions ease
but is public patience waning Sam code
Sky News